we start tonight with another mountain
lion sighting in the valley right in the
middle of a las vegas apartment complex
thank you for joining us tonight i'm
bryan loftis and i'm denise valdez
people who live there
watched as authorities moved in to get
the intruder out
madison kimbrough joining us with more
on this latest encounter madison
yes valley residents at this apartment
complex you see behind me woke up to
an unusual scene this morning when a
mountain lion
was seen roaming the property now
residents on high alert
as they received a message from complex
officials warning them about the
situation and telling them
to stay indoors the mountain lion was
crouched down behind a car
and when the department of wildlife
arrived metro assisted blocking off the
area trying multiple times to sedate the
animal but
with no luck wardens made the decision
to then euthanize the wild
cat kevin granite a resident of the
apartment complex caught the whole thing
on camera
as he peered through his window and says
police moved swiftly
i was going to be leaving early in the
morning and thought i'd take my dog for
a walk around the complex where i live i
opened up my curtains
and there's a mountain lion walking
around the property where i live that's
when the police started to arrive
and they were very fast getting there
and then the game wardens
and then the animal control
so far this year mountain lions have
been spotted in the northwest and west
valley area
the likelihood of seeing a mountain lion
in your neighborhood or
in neighboring towns is greater
according to officials due to the heat
that we are experiencing
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now madison
thanks prior to that incident the most
recent sighting in the northwest valley
close to floyd land park the department
of wildlife called in staff tranquilize
and then return the cat to its habitat
some things to remember if you come
across a lion
do not approach it just report it it's
also important to keep an eye on pets
especially when they're out at night